welcome to Startalk I'm Neil deGrasse
Tyson your personal astrophysicist and
today we're doing cosmic queries edition
and today it's on any topic in the
cosmos a kind of stellar smorgasbord and
today we have in studio comedian iliza
shlesinger did I say it right if anyone
could do it it would be you I just
assumed you didn't do it right now what
hope is there out there so you so you
are the you were the first woman and the
youngest person ever to win last Comic
Standing yeah
Wow so forget the first woman you're the
youngest person ever that this person
Trump's okay that information prevails
[Laughter]
joke at this point so you and and you
you're on TBS with a show separation
anxiety sounding show yeah it's uh it
sounds nerve-wracking and it is and it
should be as it's supposed to be it was
athlete to athlete entitled and uh it
does well just it's a new show yeah time
this airs it'll be it's it's a hit show
on TV canceled one or the other the
canceled show we've already shot so many
turn all the shoes taking someone you
know really well we separate you and
then you have to pick the questions that
the person you know is getting quizzed
on okay and then hope they get it right
there's a quarter million dollars at
stake but they don't know that oh I
think well now they do because they just
see you on the show sorry though for
that you've to live under a rock to
participate next season I got you there
you go there you go so as our longtime
fans no cosmic queries is when we bring
an in-house co-host comedian who reads
questions from the universe of the
universe drawn from our fan base and
I've not seen the questions and we just
have fun with it and if I don't know the
answer I'm gonna tell you about if I
don't know the answer or to ask you if
you don't answer I absolutely don't know
the answer then where
we go to we move on you know how long
I've spent staring at the cosmos
wondering where my uber is spent a lot
of time in space that brings to mind if
we if if space travel becomes a thing we
would need Ober space craft yeah that
would be interesting college kids all
over the place really I got a great way
to make some money yep and the kid
there's no collisions yeah actually it's
much harder to collide in if you're
moving in three dimensions then if
you're only moving in to say this all
the time it's a profound fact think
about traffic jams you're in a traffic
jam because you're on a road you can't
go over or a single plane join it's not
only in your single plane on a road
you're on a one-dimensional path right
right typically there's more than one
lane though regardless if you're stuck
in traffic all you have to do is go
above or below introduce another
dimension
you can pass all the traffic like this
that's why we need space cars in the
future they always have them going
through bill no that was my future that
we tried to come up with and failed
oh good like so the fifth element was
your idea all those cats lying cars we
you know we've been dreaming flying cars
since the 1950s I know and it will be a
thing and it's gonna be terrible the
flying car is no different from having a
lot of bridges and tunnels right it's
you to go above and below it's a lot
different in that there's nothing
holding you to where you are you got a
bridge you have to stay on that bridge a
flying car is just like yeah however if
the if the engine breaks of a flying car
you are falling brick true that's a
difference between being on a bridge or
in a tunnel right okay so there's pros
and cons I think we do have flying cars
they're called helicopter yeah but was a
really helicopter is so expensive I've
actually had that thought I'm like is
there a way to get a helicopter I feel
like these statistics for helicopters I
feel like they crash a lot well because
when the motor goes out it's you know up
in a plane if the engines die it's a
glider for yeah and a helicopter of the
engines died straight down go straight
down it shouldn't be an option that let
the engines die like that you shouldn't
be an option
[ __ ] happens Frank right so they're
gonna have to have like like meteoroid
insurance or like asteroid insurance if
you fly through space and you get hit by
one yeah they're like farmers like that
would be one W I hadn't thought about
that but yeah yeah you could be hit by a
micrometeorite going five miles per
second that would ruin your day yeah
debris from like our last space shuttles
that happens
in part it's a daisy okay so what do you
have okay so do I do the patreon page
what was your first time doing this
hope it's not your hope it's not your
last time you hope it's not my last as
well okay we'll be that will judge that
I'll be the judge that's why I gave you
the dough eyes trying to flirt my way
she's not gotten me far okay so go for
it these first so what happens we have
our patreon supporters one of the
guarantees they get it says if they ask
a question for cosmic queries then we
get to ask their question first okay so
I'm gonna ask this one because there was
so my mana read it with the emphasis mmm
and the enthusiasm and the fervor that I
feel they wrote this way yeah go for it
feel feel them yeah I think this person
is also a fellow Jew you're not Jewish I
am okay here we go from Michael Cohen in
Augusta Georgia there's a Jew there dr.
Tyson this question burns in my mind I
asked NASA and wasn't satisfied with
their answer hmm if light can't escape a
black hole then doesn't that mean that
the escape velocity of a black hole
beyond the event horizon exceeds the
speed of light itself could black holes
be the exception to the speed of light
as we know it
thank you at cosmic Cohen wow that was
beautiful
okay that was totally you embodied
whoever that Cohen person is omitted the
fact that you misused then instead of
then nobody did I say then oh no he did
oh okay putting out the one part that I
understand which is literature be nice
he's the one Jew in Augusta Georgia I
represent okay that was the question
about oh yeah so it's the question is
stated accurately there are two ways to
think about the black hole one of them
is that beyond inside the event horizon
the escape velocity is greater than the
speed of light that's kind of a
classical way to think about it but what
has actually happened is the space-time
curvature has basically closed in on
itself there is no path out of the black
hole that you can take no matter what
and so not even a beam of light can get
out so that is all true you can't get
out by the way just because the speed of
light required just because to get out
of a black hole requires you travel
faster than light doesn't mean that you
are and so I mean you can't no it
doesn't mean you can right right right
we're all cool relativity is fine Julie
hypothetical because you physically
can't do it correct so it's all in fear
there's no known law of physics or
observation that would enable you to
escape a black hole even if you take the
subway like correct so so yeah yeah so
I'm disappointed that they couldn't get
a good answer from NASA I wonder where
they asked feel like NASA was like
please stop tweeting at us
the Russians are hot on our tail we've
got bigger things to deal with you stop
here's a mug and a hat how did you know
that because they're always hot on our
tail haven't you movies okay would you
like a real question any for the UM give
me whatever you got okay this one's is
the Martian based on a true story I'm
just kidding I'm not authorized to
answer that I saw that movie and I was
like I guarantee if I tweet this people
will be like oh my god I thought so I
read the book alright this is from Jeff
Church ins at Jeff Church in does space
smell oh yeah so I I once tweeted an
answer to that question so somebody is
not a follower you know what go back and
look it up
you're lazy and there's no lazy in space
there's no lays in space so here's what
happens
smell is a chemical phenomenon and it
involves molecules interacting with your
your your olfactory glands and it's in
the vacuum of space where they're not
insufficient molecules to trigger that
no you're not smelling a damn thing so
it has to do with the molecules outside
and inside it's not just molecules are
outside they come inside and then you
have smell what was outside right you're
inhaling so now here's a way to smell
something if you face the Sun and the
Sun starts singeing your your your skin
on your face then you'll then it'll burn
and then you'll smell the burning flesh
what are you facing the Sun though no
closer yes if you're close enough and
you make this yeah it'll all get singed
and you'll smell you'll smell the
descent
outer skin layers that's horrific I'm
just saying you want to smell some and
space that's how you smell smells
evidence-base wait that why we sneeze
when we stare at the Sun because it's
slowly singeing our nose hairs I haven't
that's never happened to me who told you
that that happens to do it if I gotta
sneeze or
sometimes any light source even
artificial and you go like that they
stare right at the Sun if you gotta
sneeze really on the verge of sneezing
and you feel you're going to lose it if
you're gonna lose your nasal orgasm
stare right at the Sun lose your nasal
orgasm sneezes a nasal orgasm I've not
heard that how great do you fell to his
knees and then like a little guilty it's
good no no but you have to watch out
because there are things you feel good
after only because the act of leading up
to it made you feel bad that's
interesting yeah okay but you have to
pee real bad and then you peeing feels
good well it only feels good because you
felt miserable right up to that moment
so anything feels getting back to
homeostasis so I'd had a lot of
syllables and they were I know a lot
that's good I was asked here back NASA
we did our homework
give me after this guy so so you need
air molecules some kind of gaseous
molecules to and so that always had me
wondering in spacesuits if they're not
properly ventilated you could just smell
yourself in this in a space well
provided it doesn't swap out your co2
right yeah yeah you could if you fart it
I don't I don't know if the space I
should I'd ask one of our astronauts we
have someone answer you back at NASA
asked if like below your waist effluence
is mix with above your waist effluences
like do burps and farts mix if that's
the case you'll smell your all of your
body effluence is but I bet that is mine
I don't care this true people have a
much higher tolerance of their own
gaseous effluences than that of others
sure where someone needs to look into
that I I think I know why why okay all
theories all hypotheses entertained okay
so okay here's what I think all
hypotheses considered except for just
mine so when you smell something like
we're trained to if you smell like a
fart or poop like you know that it
smells bad like in our brains because
that's telling us that it's dead and
it's not something that we should eat
you shouldn't eat it yes I think if it's
coming out of yourself somehow like
there's a disconnect where it because
it's from you maybe kind of like if your
own baby is ugly you don't see it as
ugly okay when it comes from us we're
not as grossed out so we're
psychologically
not completely reject right okay all
right that's gotta be somewhere all
right the spectrum we got top people we
can put on this okay I haven't seen any
so far to produce one gene or lunch in
there there's my managers over here all
right okay here we go
um dog is on the floor they're looking
for learning Liat you looking for
answers yes we all we all answers I came
here first person in a 12 block radius
okay I'm just gonna read you a long one
mmm nope Sara win bail Jenny from
facebook says do you think that
spacecraft using photon propulsion is a
reality I read several news articles
stating we can use a laser
she wrote laser to propel spacecraft to
Alpha Centauri in just 15 years and to
Mars in just days is this the same
concept as a light sail it is precisely
the same concept great next why so next
question yeah so you have your sail and
you have lasers on earth well so here's
what happens so your sail can work with
the Sun with sunlight and it can move
you to greater and greater orbits and
you can move to Mars or wherever else
and it's a constant source of
acceleration so this works and if you
keep accelerating the speed that you
measure for yourself is constantly
growing this a like a solar panel it's
uh no no solar panel solar panel takes
the sun's energy sunlight and turns it
into energy you'd use for something else
this is simply a sail does you hold up
the sound somebody hits the sail it
bounces off and the recoil the the
momentum transferred to the sail pushes
you forward that's all it is but now
what happens if you're so far away from
the Sun that the sun's energy that they
did not strong enough so you take mondo
lasers from Earth aim it at the sail and
continue to push it along its way and
lasers can go very very deep into space
yes not into a well you can go into a
black hole but not come out again out I
do exactly that's the right answer you
got it so that that's a good question
nicely worded thank you there no weird
questions here these are like like text
book literally send these to me ten
minutes before I walk oh my gosh okay
all right all right I think the
important thing was that you gave an
accurate answer not that I read a bit as
long as you look smart if you could
fight thank you for making me look smart
okay that is it okay if I could fight
Stephen Hawking was that one
okay here's one cuz I recognize these
words from science class okay
pulsars quasars what did you major in in
college it was a film major which is why
I'm here
no major okay why this background is
okay okay yeah you're in you're in a
galaxy right there yeah okay
my favorite part of green screen is put
your hand into someone else's oh that's
a wide shot we didn't go with me on that
one that's fine pulsars quasars magnet
ARS neutron stars white dwarfs black
holes are all of them simply dying stars
yes next question I'll look first no no
they're all different
okay give me the list again so I just
white dwarfs on that list she is on the
list okay the Sun when it dies white
little people like oh is that really
yeah okay and we don't say black holes
we say ever get American oh yeah you're
right
just try and yeah that's right over
there so I meet you a better question
everyone knows they're dying did you
hear about the the greeting card that
talked about black holes and someone's
thought they would talk about black hos
and end like the n-double-a-cp got all
enraged but no one do the research I
know looked at the car if black hole and
other physics concepts are not in your
vocabulary you have no other way to
think about black hole other than black
hole I mean that's the same I try I try
to jump in and say this is an education
problem not a racist problem is a huge
it's an it's an homage so all of these
are the dying states of stars stars of
different mass and we we our Sun will
die as a white dwarf which is a object
the size of the earth and all the rest
of the mass of the Sun will be will
escape into space and make a beautiful
nebula which we call a well there call
actually called planetary nebulae that's
myth there miss named but they're
beautiful is very cliche nebulae and you
look you look if you google planets have
neither you know that's a galaxy but
planetary nebulae are just gorgeous
stunning displays it looks like cotton
candy on there yeah oh that's one no no
Crab Nebula was the death of a supernova
which leaves a neutron star a pulsar in
its
so the Crab Nebula has a but you go down
to the center of the crab neighborhood
there is a rapidly rotating neutron star
pulsing radio waves and when these
puppies were first discovered we thought
they were there was so perfectly timed
that people thought that maybe there's
an intelligent civilization sending us
just angles you probably can't close to
because if it's a radio wave well well
if if too intense is bad for you but
we're at enough good enough distance so
our radio telescopes detected it but no
they were not l GM's little green men
which is how they were first written LG
yeah someone says it's an LG M or not I
like how they're labeled green before we
even saw them yeah plus plus we want
them to be small so that we can dominate
them oh yeah no no no whatever imagines
be GM's you know big green man you know
there's there's the bgf over BFG beer
with the Roald Dahl book it's about
giant big okay yeah they're probably not
big I would imagine aliens might be
taller than us but not heavier as they
were in Avatar there were 90 feet tall
yeah which is a Bible that's wrote
that's a rhetoric that's good perfect
but that's you're gonna that's how it's
gonna be that's what that's what's gonna
go sure okay movies are always right
eventually blue people they could be
blue you know what pisses me off about
that movie right okay they're all
connected what they got this USB
ponytail the way they can connect to
their to their flying horses
and all of nature is one when it was
time for them to fight yeah the best
that could happen was the the
rhinoceroses came and that was it I'm
thinking if you could summon all the
power of all the living creatures on
your planet oh my gosh but if like every
tree would come and swat you oh my if
you had the pet if you could talk to
them through your ponytail right excuse
me they should have totally kicked ass I
remember inter cranial Bluetooth
capabilities I can't even get my phone
to connect to my Civic Furness any other
armies I'm just saying they had way more
powerful power that they could have
tapped given the premise of that story
right and they actually did be the
messages like when it come times to come
time to war and all they ended up there
praying and stuff and I'm thinking you
have the power over nature put nature to
work here right you know nature what can
nature do for you
when you run for desitin lately so you
know for me lately nature thanks for all
the shade jerks well this is a question
what would be on because you said our
son's gonna die yeah yeah son it's
totally gonna die we'll be on our son's
tombstone I I burn I burn the candle at
both ends
how about that yeah more tombstone
options when star talk continues for our
second segment of cosmic queries with at
least Eliza tell me let me hear you guys
are solution girl iliza shlesinger
paparazzi were taking pictures Slesinger
all right we'll be right back this is
Startalk we're back and I'm your host
Neil deGrasse Tyson your personal
astrophysicist my day job is at the
American Museum of Natural History where
I serve as the director of the Hayden
Planetarium and I have with me iliza
shlesinger
you read that in your bio I was like
Hayden Planetarium I'm here yeah so so
you you you wonder you you you do
stand-up across the country the world in
the world
very cool does it does it translate to
other countries they're usually English
speaking when I said translate but does
the humor translate not the language
language it does actually no um because
they they get our pop culture you're
asking me to come there it's because
you're a fan of my comedy you already
know yeah what this American weirdo does
but I'll do for the troops I've done a
lot of shows the McCool's always um very
fulfilling yeah fine and just in London
oh god their English is far superior to
ours so we think they think and we the
first I ever heard the Beatles speak
horrific oh my gosh what lad I had no
idea I was at the kid and I didn't know
what the hell that's all they're all
British people when you hear that and
then you hear them sing and then it does
like just seeing everything from then on
looks like a fries and coke don't want
to sound like the other culture just
sing then
and we're good before we left off you
challenged me to come up with a app
attack for the dead son and I and I said
I burned my candles at both ends and
that was a little lame I think and I
want another chance okay do you have one
I have one okay okay what the epitaph on
the sons tombstone should be sick burn
bro okay let's okay I got one
okay this has spoken to Earthlings who
long went extinct okay I tried oh that's
so sad about I couldn't take the heat
for this skill applies literally to no
other Avenue in my life yes the Sun okay
you had one question that I felt I could
answer in one answer really okay go go
that gives me one fewer that I got an
answer go Cory moon at SF moon when they
moon yeah I love it what phase is he
full good ok SF moon 101 maybe maybe sad
and he's a blue moon he's a blue moon
yeah yeah ok what do you have I don't
know any other moons a Blood Moon a
Harvest Moon Harvest Moon Harvest Moon
what kind of sicko came up with that one
maybe he's amber and he's a honeymoon is
that a thing yeah yeah honeymoon is the
honeymoon full moon I'm so focused on
not sounding like an idiot that I'm like
a honeymoon great it's the celestial
reference the June a full moon is the
honeymoon ok so you're not out of many
people don't know it but it is and
that's how you get honey one that most
men try to avoid possibly but but I
wonder if if June was not the
traditional marriage month and then what
would the vacation you take after
wedding be called if you named it after
those moons have very different sets of
sets a name that's why yeah there's a
wolf moon there's a Snow moon there's a
snow no snow moon well it's in the
winter moon its agrarian I mean it came
from sounds very Asian no moans no moon
it just does okay but I'm just saying
there are a lot of
sheral references to moons and the
honeymoon isn't so named because its arc
across the sky remains very low and it
retains the colors of sunset its entire
path out which is a deep amber and so it
has an amber color even at its brightest
and so it's a honeymoon by far correct
okay correct that's what do you have me
there the queries yes has a nuclear bomb
ever been tested in space if so what
happened please visit Utah and my answer
is yeah that's Utah that's how we got
Utah terrible all right
so mmm so we have never tested a nuclear
bomb he's on the Russians no but the Sun
is a nuclear bomb therefore it is being
tested in space continually we speak by
all stars throughout the galaxy and the
universe may be his epitaph will be
testing one two and then nothing what
happens if I put these molecules these
atoms together so the difference is when
we and when we create thermonuclear
fusion
it is uncontrolled and it's a bomb when
the Sun creates thermonuclear fusion
it's controlled and it's a star so
that's the difference we don't know how
to control it how come when you do it
it's a star but when I do it it's a bomb
it sounds like an argument like a
teenage galaxy arguing with this how can
you do it that would be the Sun has to
be a badass
argument son of the Sun Sun could invoke
that argument now now the two times
nuclear weapons have ever been used in
warfare they were detonated in the air
not on the ground oh really yes
I didn't know that yes and that is the
birth of the concept of ground zero
it is the spot on the ground beneath the
location of the explosion yeah well
that's which is the closest point and
with their people who might calculate
this how do you maximize the blast
radius to kill and damage the most you
know exactly how much the rate is so you
figure out how what is the rate that
this would grow how much damage will it
have how much energy does it have
therefore what is the altitude is about
a kilometer up so that was detonated in
the air
then there were nuclear test ban treaty
x' that came out and one of them said
you can't do it on Earth's surface so
then they did it underground service
well then they would scattered
radioactive materials right so if you do
it underground then all the radioactive
stays underground no soil in the soil in
that one spot so you pick a spot where
nobody lives and you do it there and
they were banned entirely and so there's
got to be like half lives or something
it can't just be like contain like it
there's it for sure it's hard it's very
hard for radioactivity to penetrate
through soil it's very hard
yeah but there are a lot of really
really empty places on earth Utah at
home of the new of NASA's proud new I
know NASA doesn't do radioactive nuclear
testing but but maybe one day Utah all
right what else you have this is this
apply the way this is cosmic queries
grab-bag so whatever you know cosmic
queries grab-bag I was doing a great job
of picking than myself and then the
producer came in and she was like you
need to get better at this and so she
went through and labeled them for me
like you are [ __ ] up suppose I have
some constitution here and you're just
you're coming in there it's a very too
much base okay Lou Newcomb at Lou
Newcombe Newcomb Edison and you Kem and
ewc OMB we were just talking about nukes
eyes I'm sorry I have nukes on the brain
surely it's apropos is active it's not
steady its SETI ready you can pronounce
it yeah we pronounce it we say the
acronyms here
SETI these active SETI a good idea do
you agree with dr. Hawking that it could
be risky yes well well so I don't okay
so SETI we're searching for life in the
universe fine
that's the acronym search for
extraterrestrial intelligence okay okay
you didn't know what that's before nope
everybody news 100 way makeup artist PR
person manager log on the floor daddy
dog
Blanche right did you know Eddie yeah
she knew it yeah I'm just yeah well
because it's easier so here's the thing
so we are looking for life now the two
ways of engaging SETI one of them is
looking for life in all the wrong places
earned we turn out
scopes and aim into places and just see
if anyone's trying to talk to us all
right
that's one way we're looking for life
that's actually pretty safe because if
we find life they have no idea where we
are unless we send signals so Hawking is
concerned that if we start sending
signals announcing where we are envision
a location and and and what we're saying
then maybe we would be prime prime
candidates for being enslaved or taken
over or whatever so he's worried that
it's a bad idea to announce our presence
but in fact there was not a damn thing
we can do about it because we already
have and for the past 80 years our radio
signals and our and our television
signals have been leaking out from our
atmosphere when they talk about being on
the air the air has nothing to do with
it radio signals move through the dead
of space like it's nobody in soil they
go through soil a certain depth of soil
radio waves can go through a certain
depth Home Depot they have a special
well they penetrate through walls and
buildings that's why anyway it's going
on anywhere kitc so the earliest signs
that of life on Earth have already been
established and they're traveling
through space at the speed of light at
the speed of light speed of light
billions of light-years away at this
point no no no only it's billions 80
light years they've gone so far I will
agree to say you're wrong right so 80
years ago when they began so how far
away can they possibly be by now you
tell me do you like yours well you like
because they're traveling the speed of
light okay in regular years is how many
years 80 years the same thing no no no
because it's four years to travel 80
light years now if you want to say
billions so 80 times five point eight
trillion that's how many miles away this
limit miles there you go 10 years so so
80 times five point eight trillion so
it's eight times four it says fifth yes
400 yeah you figured I don't let you say
it I don't want embarrass you yes so it
so be four hundred trillion
close with the 4 yeah 400 trillion miles
times 5 is 40 very good yeah so it's far
but the point is it's going out when we
couldn't control all I'm saying is it
has washed over exoplanets that may have
some kind of life possibly intelligent
life and if they have the tools to
detect our signal they will infer what
our culture was like and I said there's
many times before on the show and we
just have to suck it up that their first
encounters will be things like The
Honeymooners totally learn how men and
women treat one another from seeing the
honeymooners everyone's all the men are
fat and all the women stay at home right
and the men threaten bodily harm harm to
their wives right right why I uh
you know well I think it's also where
there's so many variables to that we're
assuming that if it's intelligent life
it's more intelligent than us and it's
understanding there's so many it's so
it's such a small equation that would be
they're smarter than us and know we're
doing enter warmongering people right so
so as the reason why I'm looking for us
reason why I don't agree with Hawking
because that's what started this I know
I'm Hawking is feels they might have
evil motives and I claim and by the way
if they come visit us in response to our
signal they are far more advanced than
we are because we're still just driving
around the block boldly going where
hundreds have gone before in low-earth
orbit so we haven't even been anywhere
in 40 years and I look like we're going
anywhere anytime soon so if they come
here they're more advanced than us so
he's worried that a more advanced
civilization coming upon earth might
then enslave us and I'm saying that
while that may be true his fear derives
not from scientific evidence he is his
fear comes from what he thinks aliens
will do but he's basing that on what he
knows humans will do sure what else
could you base it off of the citizen
behavior he's so he's assuming that
aliens are as evil and as war mongering
as humans also read guardians of galaxy
okay before it became a movie
but yeah it's an assumption and it's all
maybe aliens are better than us in every
way that matters
can I that I said during the break with
that was that aliens are an advanced
form of humans visiting us from the
future oh okay look at their brains are
bigger all right eyes are bigger which
are things you would need to use like a
nice eyeliner okay all right I've hair
we don't really need hair they don't
have sex organs presented which is kind
of an animalistic thing okay and there
seem to be very small how do they mate I
mean how do they know who to me still
have sex organs like fish don't have
boobs you noticed but I bet to fish
that's totally happen if she dressed
nice for me once in a while I would pay
attention to her how they have sex like
aliens do remember the Chi animals have
no problems finding out who didn't boo
to mate
all right all right so the aliens don't
even know we need a lesson or which is
the male snake and which is the female
say they don't have any problems so
neither do the aliens
so put your elbow to mine I don't know
what they do something gross and it's
obviously elbow sex slow sex
all right here's what okay Tim wall at
Tim wall 2016 so we just got that handle
if an astronaut jump where he was just
born this year their birth year and
their handles go on but astronaut jumped
on a diving board on the moon what he
bounced higher or lower than on earth I
know the answer mm-hmm yeah yeah so the
the diving oh you know the answer well
let's hear it I got a bounce there's no
gravity on the moon yeah yeah there is
gravity on the moon otherwise the
astronauts would just been floating
there rather than walking me one day
people they were walking yep there's
gravity on the moon yeah yeah just to
think they're gonna hire yeah you go
higher yes I need that yeah yeah so well
no no just just to be clear the the so
one of them is you're trying to set mass
into motion okay and your mass is your
mass no matter where you are but for a
given amount of recoil that same recoil
will then send something farther on the
moon that it would otherwise here on
earth so
that's why on the moon when they hopped
they hopped what very far than they did
here on earth that's good even though
they had 200 pounds worth of or more of
life support because tour Japan they
weigh one-sixth so 200 pounds would
weigh only how much half of one set one
six would you say so no so on the moon
day it's 1/6 gravity trying to set my
chin that's it so on moon is one-sixth
gravity so the 200-pound thing on earth
would weigh one-sixth at six of that on
that I can't do that I have which on his
flat I put you on the spot you know you
make up for the factor that you said it
had no gravity at all that was your way
to just me getting nervous about
interplanetary discussions with a
renowned so so so it's less gravity and
you can do a lot of fun things you can
like the baseball games would be really
interesting and you couldn't throw a
curve ball cuz you need air to move it
against it I dunno
you know you go into space and you
jumped if you were out of an orbit and
in outer space of a diving board you
would just continue you wouldn't even
correct because objects in motion tend
to stay in motion Sir Isaac Newton yes
give it up for ELISA like and your head
you're like please don't say her name
wrong yes very good so you have two eyes
you took you take physics long time like
long and no remember that no long enough
long ago enough that I could have
forgotten it but I have respect for
physics good as we all should because
these are these are not just good ideas
they are the laws they're the laws
sometimes at home a very small counter
and I dropped my things off my like
makeup counter though every time
something falls I yell angry okay what's
next
please stop and just read the questions
Bobby tender flake that is the cutest
last name Bobby tender flake
sounds like a southern light come here a
little tender flake okay Bobby tender
flake which is either a porn name or
you're very close to nature you know let
me tell you my porn name so it's it's a
toughy Arlington why is it like you this
the street you grew up on it yeah yeah
and there Dan your first time yeah
got to be more cosmos related what can I
do that's what strike and choose what
street I grew up on that just Arlington
well then I have to invent one formula
it's your favorite nebula and your
favorite subatomic particle okay that
would be the crab boson have to say crab
juice is the only nebula I know there's
an ointment for that there's an ointment
for that
Bobby tender flake at heavy sweating
well there's your poor name right there
heavy sigh wait 20 seconds in the
segment go if I went to pee on Pluto
with the pee freeze before I hit the
ground yes it would be great it would it
would you'd make a pea Ark yes and then
you would die because there's no air for
you to breathe freeze - yeah you just
got your dick out yeah and by the way
you don't have to do that up there
playing other places in the solar system
you can pee and have it freeze in
midstream and I do that on Pluto can I
still do it
can I make a peace beer good art you're
saying it would Ark yeah well because
that's just the the trajectory of it
wouldn't freeze before it got to that
reject it wouldn't matter what still
follow the arc you don't think it would
freeze a millimeter outside of your job
because it's a body temperature its body
temperatures so it's got a drop
temperature then change state and only
then does it freeze okay we've got a
clip of that coming up when we come back
more cosmic queries with iliza
shlesinger all right we're back in stock
talk cosmic queries edition with the
lightest that looks like you're baring
it Schlesinger
how's that is that better slicing is
that better so it's what's your what
some of your favorite material when you
do stand up my love stand up by the way
it's my favorite thing ever of anything
really yes yes and not enough women we
could get some more women please because
the first time I heard women do stand-up
oh my gosh there's a whole swath of
culture I've never heard joked about it
on it's evolving now I mean I am I'm in
- you're asking me my favorite material
of my material yeah yeah if you like if
you guys
you can check out my Netflix specials
and Warpaint and a third one coming out
Netflix best oak like do you onstage on
TV yeah on Netflix okay I'm there on
streaming television okay okay your
programming and like nonlinear in
mathematics is done with all the great
things that happen in the world are
nonlinear yeah yeah that's true
especially in TV now room is killing it
I don't know observation social
observations between men and women I
love self-deprecation I really like
aggressive humor i I look at stand-up
comedy is more of like a series of
sketches with one person okay what
you're saying fashion so it's colorful
it's textured it's cosmic yes not a crab
nebula crab boson yeah I love bosons
I'll have the seared crab boson thank
you okay so give it to me I should for
you is yeah maybe we can fit in go more
Emily care boss at Emily care I don't
understand what that being a so it's at
Emily care which is an old-age home for
only women named Emily what are the what
are the frontiers of research in
astrophysics right now
Oh right now we're looking for Dark
Matter we don't know what is causing 85%
of the gravity of the universe we don't
know what is making the yeah yeah I'm
not even done right and there's a
pressure in the vacuum of space making
the universe accelerate in its expansion
against the wishes of all the great
level of all the galaxies that it
contained if you add up dark matter and
dark energy it is 96% of all that is
driving the universe and we haven't a
clue what they are dark side is winning
its star wars the dark side is
definitely winning winning this contest
of so they're just pulling yes and we
don't know what it is but we can measure
it what does it have to do with we
should even Clive said we shouldn't call
it dark matter dark and that implies we
know it's matter and energy we didn't
know what the hell it is it's evil
though it's you know it's evil and it's
out there and it's pulling because it's
dark creating stretch marks on the
universe are too and we're looking for
life in the universe life on Mars like
Europa and Hawking is like no this could
be probably micro-b I don't think
there's intelligent life lurking in
caves on Mars but
life at all would be a boon to biology
hey fine for no otter bits on Mars yeah
but not intelligent life that's
different yeah I think it's a little
rude to call them it's a jump to jump to
go from losing water to intelligent life
with civilizations Hollywood so your
definition of intelligence yeah so I
would say that plus on the bio
biological side which affects the search
for life we don't know how to turn
organic molecules into self-replicating
life that transition with which earth
did without aid apparently without any
issues any help without any help we so
we don't know how to do that yet so
that's an interesting frontier once you
figure that out you can better decide
what planet it might be happening on
right yeah there's your answer
bring it on care for only Emily's Mike
armed armed enemy that our mo 15mm which
specific sci-fi movie look at the camera
because I am a trained professional
specific sci-fi movie would you like to
see remade because the idea was fine but
the execution was awful
Oh some enemies right here today Oh mmm
made my least favorite genre so I got it
okay they did The Day the Earth Stood
Still a second time and was they they it
was different but I thought it was it
could have been better but it was good
callate him it was good it was good
The Day the Earth Stood Still because
that was first in what the 50s or early
60s and then the next one had Keanu
Reeves and so and a few others Kathy
Bates was in it so but didn't have how
many times we can do it so so I would
say the blob I think they should be
making the walk that's just okay I guess
I think sci-fi I think he was looking
for more of like a space movie oh well
blot is an alien that sucks your blood
and it was not an actor in a costume
what about invasion of the body
snatchers I wasn't done poorly in the
first place I'd like to see a remake it
was remade a remake of the remake oh
really really
okay talked about originals
yeah how about voyage to the moon people
that's all the people line up they have
a big rocket and the rocket shoots and
it hits the moon I ever saw these
smashing pumpkins did a video and they
had the voyage the moon forgot the
French word it's Mille Miglia well it's
French a loon ya know the Lumiere sorry
that's who did it alright boy to the
movie no big deal no big deal STF for
terrestrial life acronym call back
there's a call back from the acronym
from before SDF searching for
intelligent life
I said II Betty said it was a stupid
acronym because STFU you know right
that's right okay boys the moon yeah it
was it was what like 15 seconds long 15
seconds well I think we should redo that
in a full moon on vine what type of
music do you listen to the most are you
inspired by music and/or the Arts I'm
deeply and always and as long as I can
remember have been inspired by the arts
and my brother is an artist he attended
the High School of Music and Art in New
York City I attended the Bronx High
School of Science so very geeky very
nerdy everything you think it would be
is what it was the brain covered totally
totally covered and I grew up with a kid
artist who's now an adult artist so that
kept me sensitized I think and so I
value what role artists contribute to
society and people say you know what
value is art to the security of our
nation you know there's like bankers you
get people who say that but the answer
is you know the fact that we do art
makes the country worth defending the
fact that we're allowed to create art
yes yes yes and I listen to almost every
genre of music that I can even think of
I'd like creativity no matter how it
manifests but if I were to pick one for
the Desert Island Discs or I would say
for the space mission
alright have a discman on a desert
island so no just my playlists for my
space mission would be heavily
represented in the
I'm deeply yeah I love the blues if I'm
driving a car at night and the Blues
comes on the radio or whatever I'm
listening to I got it like slow down go
to the right-hand lane feel that just
feel it feel it every white girl
secretly saying wishes she could sing
really sing like that yeah that soul
yeah you want it he's got to mean
something coming out of you like Janis
Joplin right okay so you're saying
although say I wouldn't you suppose she
was more suppose she wasn't so depressed
and live long as she'd be more
productive than she wouldn't have been
janitor would've been even more
depressing thing about a forever
what does she from Dallas or from Texas
somewhat I don't know that would have
been rammed down our throats good year
two of Texas history well she didn't X
off anymore for me so I'll just do one
that I okay what does antimatter do we
have access to it that question by
Andrew Sinclair on Facebook I wonder if
these are people who have labs in their
basement and they're gonna become like
how do I get my so as far as we have
been able to measure all particles of
matter have an exact replica of those
particles except they're made of what we
call antimatter doppelgangers which if
they come together they will completely
annihilate and turn into pure energy and
so it's and it's not just we discovered
at first it was not science science
fiction does some stuff first we did
this first right all right we came up
with antimatter the predicted its
existence discovered it how you discover
it oh so it's the product of other
reactions so you have regular matter you
smash particles apart and in the
particle stream you see antimatter and
the antimatter doesn't last very long
you see antimatter well because then
it's yeah you see its path through it
back there cloud chambers and things you
see the the paths that hit a travel
about through soil very worried about
the nuclear so it is real and it would
be matter antimatter engines would be
the most powerful engines the most
efficient engines we would ever know how
to make if you're traveling through
space because you start with matter and
then you have pure energy and if you
know your car that you drive your you
set a civic or you were joking about a
Civic
what is it it's like only 20 or 30% at
most of the energy of the gas you put in
the engine is going to move your car
forward the risk is dissipated as heat
that's why your car gets hot when you
drive it imagine if all that meant
energy went it to propel your car you'd
be going 200 miles an hour harnessing
and harnessing energy is all about ended
energy all about that exactly and if all
your if all of your matter becomes
energy you got it there you go
who do you think will win in the race to
harnessing antimatter first us or the
Russians we have more resources than the
Russkies do so maybe with me maybe it's
us dosvedanya
all right let's go to a lightning round
get as many questions as I can and I'll
get an answer in sound bytes go do I say
the name of the person just grief ask
okay what is complete stillness would
you be slingshotted to the end of time
would you be ripped completely from
existence if you were completely still
what is complete stillness complete
stillness as far as I know would have
nothing to do with you traveling through
time or being cast out to the edge of
existence also the name of the yoga
studio and in fact nothing is completely
still there are vibrations at all levels
and even at all temperatures including
absolute zero matter vibrates next if
there but it just vibrates more if it's
hotter but even at Absolute Zero quantum
fluctuations create vibrations in matter
exactly go if there was no comet to wipe
out the dinosaurs how much harder would
it be for mammals and eventually
intelligent life to thrive could we
maybe get intelligent okay so great
question so here's the thing our mammal
ancestors were running underfoot to
t-rex trying to avoid being consumed as
hors d'oeuvres so if the comet didn't
come if the asteroid didn't come it's
not clear we would have evolved to
anything unless we were on a completely
separate continent hey where the
dinosaurs couldn't swim and then eat us
then it's possible that we could evolve
intelligence completely separately while
there were major dinosaurs existing on
another continent and then when Columbus
set sail
red cross continents yeah he was just
gotten eaten that would there was like
hats on like welcome I've seen the way
an iguana looks at you like knows
something it's like it could have been
us next right so could dinosaurs
involved intelligence not likely their
brain cavities didn't look like yeah too
small
okay next bunch of jerks do you think
there's promising progress to be made in
the unified field theory of hollow
fracture graphic universe okay so you
read that well very good very good the
holographic universe is active graphic
dot o fractal graphic well I don't know
what a hollow fractal graphic universe
is but a holographic universe I know I
think we only want it for hollow fractal
fractal graphic it was the spelling bee
no but a holographic universe is that
the the the entire universe is embedded
within a holographic map on the skin of
a black hole of things that had passed
through so it's just and maybe the
entire horizon of the universe itself
contains the record of everything that's
going on within it's an intriguing
hypothesis that has good strong
theoretical support and is still being
researched I had a whole joke about
Tupac at Coachella because they did a
hologram of him but then when you said
was so smart but I just abandon it okay
is Earth gaining mass from space dust
and impact rocks or losing mass from
evaporating gases and launching space
probes what effects would this have on
GPS satellite excellent question so we
are gaining three approximate anywhere
between two and four hundred tons of
meteor dust a day which vastly exceeds
spacecraft that we send out or lost
vaporators particles in the atmosphere
so earth is gaining mass daily
consequences that would be it is not any
worse than an elephant collecting a net
yeah it's less it's less than that these
questions are more just me trying to I
have no idea what I said when I read it
even if we someone discovered the tech
to travel at or faster than light would
passengers of the vehicle survive so
it's not the issue is not how fast you
go is what is your acceleration Excel
raishin is what kills you deceleration
is what kills you alright
so juts in a plane you're going 600
miles an hour and you just find sipping
tea that's like the speed doesn't kill
you
speed has never killed you it's all
about acceleration and I actually wrote
a little essay for Motor Trend magazine
on excel and I said it's it's it's you
know it's not all about the speed it's
all about the acceleration because
that's what you feel and that's the
feeling of going fast whether or not you
actually are that's right so no go as
fast as you want and enjoy as fast as
you want from from neil degrasse sighs
and don't wear a seat belt and enjoy
your life that's not what I said what
you just said this bump out of this
iliza shlesinger
I will look for you on Netflix and on
TBS coming to a big galaxy near you Alex
C near a stand up galaxy near you avoid
pulsars they're bad for their bad for
your matter so I'm the other grass Tyson
you've been listening to and possibly
watching Startalk and I've been your
favorite astrophysicist maybe I'm not
your favorite actress by the way if you
know more than one astrophysicist I'll
stop saying that because I will not
presume but if you only know one I will
declare that I'm your favorite
astrophysicist and although until then
I'll be signing on as usual beating you
to keep looking
[Music]